Oumuamua ist nicht allein.
Havard Professor Abraham Loeb und sein Kollege
Amir Siraj haben jetzt ein weiteres Interstellares
Objekt gefunden.
Das Objekt war allerdings sehr klein und verglühte
in unserer Atmosphäre.
Oumuamua ist ja ein extrem seltsames Objekt.
Abraham Loeb hält es ja für möglich, dass
es sich um ein Lichtsegel einer fremden Zivilisation
handelt.
Was hat es mit dem neuen Objekt auf sich?
Clixoom Science & Fiction heute mit Ronny
von Raumzeit - Vlog der Zukunft - ja und auch
bei uns gibt es regelmäßig faszinierende
Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal, nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich willkommen!
Am 8.
Januar 2014 trat ein seltsames Objekt in die
Erdatmosphäre ein.
Das beinhaltet eine Studie, die von Havard
Professor Abraham Loeb und seinem Kollegen
Amir Siraj veröffentlichte wurde.
Nach dem Oumuamua-Ereigniss durchforschten
sie den CNEOS-Katalog.
Hier sind alle Objekte erfasst, also Asteroiden,
Meteoriden, Weltraumschrott, die in in die
Erdatmosphäre eindringen können.
Am 8.
Januar 2014 wurde ein seltsames Objekt registriert.
Allerdings kümmerte sich die Forschung zunächst
nicht darum.
Es trat in die Erdatmosphäre ein und verglühte
über dem südwestlichen Pazifik.
Jetzt gingen Loeb und Siraj die Datenbank
durch und stießen auf dieses seltsame Objekt.
Es verhielt sich nämlich anders als alle
anderen Meteroiden.
Zur Erklärung: Als Meteroiden werden im Gegensatz
zu Asteroiden kleinere Objekte bezeichnet.
Sie verglühen meist vollständig in der Erdatmosphäre.
Dieses Objekt hatte einen Durchmesser von
etwa 45 Zentimetern und flog mit einer außerordentlich
hohen Geschwindigkeit.
Die Forscher berechneten Geschwindigkeit und
Flugbahn und kamen zu einem spektakulären
Ergebnis.
Die Geschwindigkeit des Objektes war so hoch,
dass die Gravitation der Sonne quasi keinen
Einfluß auf die Flugbahn hatte.
Das ist laut Loeb und Siraj aber nur möglich,
wenn das Objekt aus einem fremden Planetensystem
oder aus der Umgebung eines Sterns in unserer
Galaxie stammt, also nicht aus unserem Sonnensystem,
wow!
Ein zweites Interstellares Objekt?
Durchqueren also doch viel mehr interstellare
Objekte unser Sonnensystem, als bisher gedacht?
Die Forscher schlagen jetzt eine neue Methode
vor, um solche Objekte zu untersuchen.
Beim Eintritt in die Erdatmosphäre, wenn
diese Interstellaren Objekte verglühen, sollte
das Spektrum der Verbrennung untersucht werden,
um die Zusammensetzung zu erforschen.
Das könnte wirklich bahnbrechende Ergebnisse
liefern.
Denn so könnten wir erfahren, aus welchen
Elementen und Molekülen andere Sternensysteme
und vor allem deren Planeten zusammengesetzt
sind: Aber werden jetzt demnächst noch mehr
solcher Objekte entdeckt?
Astrophysikerinnen sind sich noch nicht sicher.
„Das Ergebnis ist interessant, doch es basiert
lediglich auf den Messwerten eines einzelnen
Ereignisses," so der Astronom Eric Mamajek
von der Nasa Jet Propulsion Labratory in den
„Science News".
Es wird also spannend, ob sich die These von
Loeb und Siraj bestätigt und wir es hier
mit einem zweiten Interstellaren Objekt zu
tun haben und ob die Erde tatsächlich viel
öfter als bisher angenommen solchen Objekten
begegnet beziehungsweise, sie unsere Bahn
kreuzen.
Vielen Dank Ronny!
So und wer noch nicht Rumzeit - Vlog der Zukunft
abonniert hat, macht es spätestens jetzt.
Hammer Themen, Hammer recherchiert, Hammer
Videos wie zum Beispiel das: Schwarzes Loch
gegen Erde Was würde passieren!